madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal la conférence de presse de
salman rushdie le goût de la liberté
retrouvée pour l'auteur des versets
sataniques après la décision de l'iran
de se désolidariser de la prime sur sa
tête
l'émotion et la honte en belgique
plusieurs manifestations après la mort
par étouffement de la jeune nigérienne
le ministre de l'intérieur suspens sa
décision de démissionner nouveaux
développements dans la sphère djamel
bouras le judoka accusé de dopage
pourrait être innocenté les instances
médicales remettent en cause les
analyses fait ce bateau au départ en
caroline du sud pour une course en
solitaire avec escales l'ex boxeur à
djerba teasé around alone trois français
en compétition dont il a bénéficié que
nous retrouvons en direct des états unis
mais tout de suite ouvrant ce journal
avec l'information de cette fin d'après
midi un homme de 36 ans un marginal
reconnaît le meurtre d'adrien
adolescents dont on avait découvert le
corps au début du mois d'août dernier
dans un blockhaus près de thionville ses
aveux ne signifie pas pour autant la
culpabilité
jérôme soûlard patrie chômage et le
mystère de la tragique disparition du
petit adrien semble donc enfin sur le
point d'être expliquée âgé de 12 ans le
garçon avait disparu un dimanche de juin
alors qu'il était parti faire du vélo
dès les premières heures de son absence
la maman et la grand-mère d'adrien était
déjà persuadé que le pire qui était
arrivé le fait qu'un assassinat il ya
quelqu'un qui a fait du mal à mon enfant
ça c'est une chose qui est certaine tout
âge je regardais verve ces carreaux
quelque chose me disais que mon enfant
était par là donc là je prends mes à
taquiner récents entretiens les choses à
elle ses enfants pratiquant le sang
deux mois après sa disparition adrien
est effectivement retrouvé mort dans ce
blockhaus à 200 mètres à peine du
domicile familial frappé violemment à la
tête le pantalon baissé
le garçon est retrouvé face contre terre
par trois sdf de thionville dans un
endroit sale sordide connu pour être le
rendez-vous des squatteurs et de
certains marginaux à thionville quelques
jours après cette macabre découverte
les trois sdf qui avait prévenu la
police sont finalement mis hors de cause
ce soir pourtant d'après nos
informations c'est un autre marginal qui
aurait avoué le meurtre du petit adrien
l'homme prénommé alex âgé de 36 ans est
paraît-il inconnu des services de police
le parfum de la liberté pour salman
rushdie dix ans après jour pour jour la
parution des versets sataniques sortant
de la clandestinité lors d'une
conférence de presse cet après midi à
londres
l'écrivain britannique a salué la
décision prise par le pouvoir iranien
mais reste conscient des risques qu'il
encourt etienne leenhardt un homme libre
ou presque est pas tout à fait anonyme
dans les rues de londres ce matin
l'écrivain salman rushdie savourer ses
premières heures de liberté
entouré discrètement de trois gardes du
corps et amicalement poursuivi par
plusieurs dizaines d'objectifs et de
caméras
je suis très heureux je suis très ému et
je crois que c'est c'est un jour très
important pour a pour la liberté et pour
la liberté d'expression
salman rushdie a ensuite raconté ces dix
années d'une vie en pointillés ses peurs
ses angoisses ses changements de
domicile fréquents et la vingtaine de
tentatives d'assassinât dont il aurait
été l'objet depuis la sortie des versets
sataniques jugé blasphématoire par
certains pays islamiques
son traducteur japonais a été assassiné
son traducteur italien et son éditeur
norvégien grièvement blessé lui voudrait
aujourd'hui retrouver une vie normale
non match et ésotérisme mener une vie
normale
ça paraît très simple et pourtant cela
m'a été refusé
faire les choses quand vous en avez
envie sortir se promener tout ça c'est
impossible lorsque l'on vit dans une
sorte de bulle sécuritaire et je ne
souhaite qu'une chose c'est revivre
normalement
est ce pour autant la fin de la traque
pour salman rushdie cet après midi à
londres des voix inquiétante même si
elles sont ultra minoritaires se faisait
en temps diane raptors sur le principe
la condamnation à mort court toujours
salman rushdie a insulté le prophète
dans son livre les versets sataniques et
pour cela selon l'islam
il doit mourir jamais à l'abri de l'acte
d'un fanatique salman rushdie restera
donc pour l'instant sous protection
policière
mais ces dix années de semi
clandestinité devrait au moins lui
fournir le sujet tout trouvé de son
prochain livre et salman rushdie à la
fin de la conférence de presse a tenu à
remercier publiquement les autorités
françaises jacques chirac alain juppé
mais aussi jack lang et catherine
trautmann pour leur soutien la belgique
en état de choc et une nouvelle fois
secoué par une crise politique le
ministre de l'intérieur tirant les
conséquences de la mort par étouffement
d'une jeune nigériane en cours
d'expulsion a donné sa démission puis
dans le cours de la journée a suspendu
sa décision
alors que les manifestations se
multiplient dans le pays jérôme bunny
michel levasseur
ils ont interrompu leurs cours à
l'université pour déposer une gerbe à la
mémoire de semir à la jeune nigériane
morte mardi soir après une tentative
brutale d'expulsion du territoire belge
plus qu'une bavure une récidive choquée
moi là c'est de répéter il faut que ça
fait il a fallu la mort d'une femme
connue parce qu on est sûr qu'il y en a
déjà eu trois de plus dix ans pour
campagne un sursaut qui je l'espère ne
sera pas sans lendemain
c'est ici dans le centre de rétention de
sténose hier qu'elle à côté de
l'aéroport de bruxelles que les
gendarmes belges sont venus chercher ce
émirats pour une sixième tentative
d'expulsion elle émue noté n'est ce
débat les gendarmes applique la
procédure habituelle comme le montrent
ses dessins réalisés par la télévision
belge
d'après une vidéo saisie par le
procureur
sa tête est calé contre un oreiller
pendant 10 minutes elle ne survivra pas
à ce traitement
blogue tobback assassin crise et
nigérians louis tobback le ministre de
l'intérieur sous le choc hier soir de la
vidéo que vient de lui montrer le
procureur il remet sa démission ce matin
le conseil des ministres refusent cette
démission
autobacs accepte de suspendre jusqu'à
demain soir ce soir le centre de sténose
hier qu'elle vient d'être vidée de ses
occupants
accueillis par des étudiants ils vont
reprendre leur errance
ils ont cinq jours pour quitter le
territoire belge
à nice une fusillade a fait ce matin
deux morts à forcené a tué d'un coup de
feu son ami que le groupe d'intervention
de la police nationale avait amené sur
place pour tenter de le raisonner
olivier théron diane sharks au milieu de
la rue deux corps un homme le meurtrier
est une femme
la victime c'est le résultat d'un drame
passionnel et de ce qui pourrait être
une erreur d'appréciation du gipn
les troupes d'élite de la police
nationale l'histoire a commencé dans la
nuit
l'amoureux éconduit a tenté de tuer son
rival avec un fusil de chasse
poursuivi par la police il s'est enfermé
dans son appartement et à lâcher des
rafales d'armé automatique avec une
grenade il menaçait de se faire sauter
le patron du gipn a tenté de calmer
l'homme voulait avant tout chose revoir
son ancienne maîtresse une heure plus
tard la police a amené la jeune femme
pour parlementer avec le forcené
apparemment des armées sur sept ans il
était là le policier ici et lui l'état
et qu'on tourne
m et elle tire au moma même moment ça
tellement de télé très vite alors lui
s'est affalé l'état la jeune fille
tombée en premier et la police alors là
là là continuer elle a achevé le
commandant du gipn blessés dans
l'opération n'avait semble-t-il pas
correctement évaluer la dangerosité du
port ce n'est la sphère de ce genre un
rapport de confiance s'établit entre le
négociateur et l'individu en question
et parfois on peut se tromper ce matin
manifestement ce personnage était pur au
tort que le jir du gipn penser le
forcené qui avait un véritable arsenal
chez lui voulait aller jusqu'au bout la
jeune femme l'a payé de sa vie le
parquet de nice a ouvert une enquête et
l'igpn l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
aussi pour déterminer précisément les
circonstances de ce drame
une lycéenne de 17 ans qui participait à
une classe verte dans le cantal situer
la nuit dernière en tombant d'une
falaise un adolescent a été gravement
blessé deux autres sont également tombés
mais leur chute a été amortie
l'enseignant et le surveillant qui
accompagnait le groupe était attendu cet
après-midi sur les circonstances de
l'accident
apparemment les quatre jeunes auraient
fait le mur devant la cour d'assises de
paris les experts que psychiatre évoque
est aujourd'hui la personnalité de
florence rey reprenant l'image d'une
jeune fille enfermée dans son histoire
avec audry maupin qui ai voté hier la
famille des deux jeunes gens dominique
verdeilhan guillaume faudra comprendre
chaque jour quelques dizaines de
personnes patientent avant de pénétrer
dans la salle d'audience
comprendre comment florence rey en est
arrivé là le public mais surtout les
jurés espérait beaucoup des
éclaircissements d expert psychiatre le
docteur michel dubec ne cache pas que le
cas de florence rey l'a un peu dérouté
hypersensible introverti instable
immature tel est le diagnostic sévère de
l'expert mais c'est dans sa relation
avec audry maupin que le psy cap trouve
une explication
florence rey dit il est passé d'une
prison à une autre d'un univers familial
clos à une relation sous influence avec
audry il faut parler poursuit michel
dubec de complémentarité des
inconscients avec audry maupin elle
n'avait pas peur du danger aucune
dangerosité aucun risque de récidive
selon les experts les avocats de
florence rey éprouve ce soir un certain
soulagement
la déposition des experts et hier celle
des familles ont quelque peu modifié
l'image de tueuse n'est soutenue par
l'accusation on l'aura compris il ne
s'agit pas pour la défense de contester
les faits mais seulement de plaider les
circonstances atténuantes
cet après midi le conseil d'état décidé
de suspendre la commercialisation du
maïs transgénique pour le ministère de
l'agriculture et saisir davantage d'une
irrégularité de procédure que d'une
question de fond les explications
nécessaires de benno à mousser et anne
guéri pour les producteurs de maïs
transgénique
tout était prêt 1500 hectares déjà
cultivée cette année pour une mise en
vente prévue dès le mois de novembre
mais voilà le conseil d'état vient de
suspendre et non d'interdire la
commercialisation de trois variétés de
semences sur les douze existantes
raison invoquée un dossier incomplet en
ce qu'il ne comportait pas d'éléments
permettant d'évaluer l'impact sur la
santé publique
un coup d'arrêt qui satisfait greenpeace
premiers plaignants dans cette affaire à
rebondissements
ce qui est très intéressant et c'est la
perspective couvre cette décision c'est
que sa relance en quelque sorte des ben
non pas seulement sur le plan juridique
mais sa relance le débat également sur
le plan scientifique et encore une fois
sur le plan des choix de société
satisfaction également chez les verts le
dossier transgéniques ont porté pour
beaucoup trop d'incertitudes
je crois qu'on peut réfléchir évidemment
à certaines utilisations et des
biotechnologies
même les ogm par exemple dans le domaine
médical les conseils de manière massive
à grande échelle à la fois pour
l'agriculture et pour l'alimentation
il faut encore faire beaucoup de
recherches avant de prendre une telle
décision décision contestée en revanche
pour novartis le principal producteur de
maïs transgénique qui préfère garder
encore espoir il membre du conseil
d'état auront l'occasion pendant ce laps
de temps à l'instruction de ce dossier
de constater d'une part de la qualité de
notre dossier
d'un point de vue scientifique du
respect de l'avis des scientifiques
spécialistes du sujet et troisièmement
du strict respect des procédures niveau
français
chaque parti va maintenant avancer ses
arguments juridiques pour faire pencher
la balance du bon côté
le conseil d'état lui statuera d'ici
trois semaines
au deuxième jour de sa visite en chine
lionel jospin est allé à la rencontre du
président yan pei ming qui inspectait
les zones les plus touchées par les
inondations
il fut question des droits de l'homme ce
qui n'a pas empêché les entrepreneurs
français d'obtenir la promesse d'un
contrat pour le métro de shanghai au
québec et en narco nord enfin ils se
sont vu le président chinois et le
premier ministre aux france un président
chinois qui d'ailleurs fait tout pour
ressembler physiquement à mao
les deux hommes auraient dû se
rencontrer à pékin mais le président
tian deming en a décidé autrement
il était officiellement en tournée
d'inspection en province en raison des
inondations
lionel jospin n'en a pas pris ombrage on
a parlé de la crise asiatique mais aussi
des droits de l'homme je lui ai dit
qu'il me semblait que le développement
économique social éducatif de la chine
ferait que cette volonté d'affirmation
des libertés et des droits de l'homme
deviendrait plus grande
même si j'étais conscient que ce serait
un processus continu moment de détente à
shanghai
la venue du célèbre moult shanghai la
plus grande ville de chine la plus
ouverte à l'économie de marché
d'ailleurs ici le français alstom a
signé une lettre d'intention pour
l'équipement du métro de la ville soit
un contrat de plus d'un milliard de
francs autre décision mais cette fois il
s'agit d'un geste humanitaire la france
a décidé d'aider les victimes des
inondations ces inondations qui touchent
actuellement la chine sont devenues un
enjeu politique il n'est pas impossible
que le régime en exagère l'ampleur car
toute cette affaire permet à l'armée de
redorer son blason et au régime de
reprendre les choses en main après ces
inondations qui ont donc ravagé le pays
ces derniers mois aujourd'hui l'heure
est à la décrue est au bilan le désastre
pour des dizaines de milliers de
personnes reportage isabelle bechler
tristan le braz
des plaines à maïs sorgho le millet à
part le pétrole qu'elles recèlent les
terres duré longtemps ne sont pas très
riche mais là elles ont carrément
disparu dans la rivière a débordé voilà
un mois nous sommes ici à 45 km du lit
de la rivière neuve nous voguons au
dessus du niveau des maïs il y environ
deux mètres de profondeur mais par
endroits me phung et que tu as fait
mètres plus bas
les habitants des maisons les plus
basses non tu que le choix de se
réfugier en hauteur sur de vagues
monticule pour habiter détente dans un
premier temps désormais il espère être
relogées real nos maisons tout était
innoncent se sont écroulés c'est la
désolation partout on vivait dans des
tentes monté provisoirement mais
maintenant il commence à faire froid
pour l'instant la mairie régler nos
problèmes de logement et nourriture nous
a donné des habits et des couvertures
on devrait planter dans six à sept mois
mais on n'y arrivera pas il est à
craindre que l'eau gèle sur place il
faudra encore hot et le sable qui
recouvre la terre pas de plantation mais
sans doute et des problèmes pour les
paysans pendant au moins trois ou quatre
ans le maire inspectent la digue
installé par les militaires bonne
nouvelle le niveau de l'eau baisse
d'environ 20 centimètres par jour
maintenant il fait de plus en plus froid
et la municipalité à trouver de
nouvelles solutions pour l'hiver des
sinistrés on a démonté les tentes et on
les évacue vers des maisons épargnées
par les inondations
c'est sans relâche que les secours se
poursuivent pour les dernières familles
isolées par l'eau évacuation tout
approvisionnement canton chantier de la
nouvelle école il avance à marché forcée
la nuit on y travaillait la lumière des
projecteurs l'ouragan george a touché
aujourd'hui les côtes de la floride
venant des caraïbes la dépression s'est
abattue sur le sud des états unis des
pluies diluviennes et des rafales de
vent l'ordre d'évacuation concerner
quelque 500000 personnes ces dernières
l'heure actuelle est que le couvre-feu a
été instauré le cyclone ne s'éloignerait
maintenant dans le détroit de floride en
direction du golfe du mexique
et puis un avion faisant la liaison
entre malaga et miliana laroque s'est
écrasé avant l'atterrissage il n'y
aurait aucun survivant
les 34 passagers et membres d'équipage
ont péri dans la catastrophe
les causes de l'accident sont pour
l'instant indéterminées politique
française à toulon avant le deuxième
tour des législatives partielles de
dimanche les leaders des partis
politiques en appelle à la mobilisation
des électeurs
le taux très élevé d abstention de la
semaine dernière 56 9% risque de jouer à
plein sur l'issue du scrutin
mais quelle d'armand yann streiff duel
sur la ville deuxième édition à toulon
en un peu plus de cinq mois
il ya 48 heures de ce deuxième tour
lorsqu'on demande comment se passe la
campagne des réponses viennent du
réflexe ça se passe tu viennes pour nous
continuons à faire notre campagne de
terrain comme l'avion ciel proximité
rencontrer les toulonnais très bien fait
très bien beaucoup à la contact avec la
population gauche plurielle contre front
national où la course poursuite après
une partie des électeurs d'une droite
laminée au premier tour on va voir ce
qui va se passer le 27 nous avons
rencontré des gens qui vous en dit nous
n'avons pas voté au premier tour parce
que nous savions qu'au deuxième tour
c'était simple en retrait quand ton
front national
quant à sandrine le chevalier candidate
d'un parti qui exalte encore aujourd'hui
l'algérie française la voilà soudain aux
côtés du général de gaulle général de
gaulle n'a pas fait tout vient enfin et
défendez l'europe des nations unies
c'est là dessus qu'on se retrouve aussi
y est je pense que c'est très importante
c'est se retrouver sur des valeurs
communes ces supposées valeurs communes
entre la droite et le front national la
gauche s'emploie cette semaine à les
dénoncer à la veille des élections
partielles de toulon et d'aubagne
les leaders ont donc pris l'avion et la
parole voilà pourquoi il faut une
nouvelle fois et cette élection sur un
symbole avec d'autres faire comprendre à
la droite qu'elle ne doit pas rechercher
son avenir vers les extrêmes car elles
cèdent tous les jours un peu plus
idéologiquement à l'extrême droite
et puis à toulon il faudra compter avec
le parti majoritaire celui des
abstentionnistes
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux ici à
se détourner des enjeux politiques
la famille de son front national rpc
sioniste
c'est pas ça que mélo et ce soit dans un
parti politique
très honnêtement je vois pas trop ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et les
électeurs toulonnais n'ont pas fini
d'être sollicité mi octobre se déroulera
ici une élection cantonale partielle de
jours maintenant de l'élection en
allemagne qui devrait déterminer
l'avenir du pays la campagne des verts à
berlin et hambourg une campagne décisive
pour ce parti qui devrait être le
partenaire incontournable du spdc
gerhard schröder l'emportent
philippe rochot pierre moscovici
les verts allemands se veulent dans la
course comme ici au dernier marathon de
hambourg
une cité dirigé par une alliance entre
les socialistes et les écologistes
un modèle de gouvernement pour yoshka
fischer en maillot noir patron des verts
allemands qui deviendra sans doute
ministre des affaires étrangères si les
sociaux-démocrates forme une coalition
avec les verts
3h40 pour un premier marathon un temps
acceptable qui relève quelque peu son
image ternie par une campagne électorale
maladroites les verts voulaient faire
passer le prix de l'essence à 15 francs
le litre pour financer des programmes
d'environnement une mesure impopulaire
au pays de la voiture nous sommes un
parti écologiste
on n'est pas l'automobile club ici alors
quand ses lieutenants font campagne
comme ici dans les immeubles délabrés du
vieux berlin où vit la communauté turque
il arrive dans ces voitures électriques
qui ne séduisent ni les étrangers ni les
allemands
christiane stroë le patron des verts à
berlin s'efforce de justifier un
programme politique jugée très durs par
une partie des allemands et qui a fait
baisser les écologistes dans les
sondages nous voulons taxer un peu plus
l'énergie et les sens et avec cet argent
alléger les charges sociales et réduire
les loyers des personnes défavorisées
avec l'augmentation du délai sens on
veut aussi obliger les gens à acheter
des voitures plus petites qui consomment
moins et qui polluent moins
les verts ne devraient pas dépasser 7%
des voix mais cette baisse dans les
sondages ne les inquiète pas les
candidats écologistes se sont tous
retrouvés à berlin pour clôturer la
campagne
ils ont joué les chansonniers en
traitant schröder de menteur oubliant
sans doute qu'ils le pourront exister
que par une alliance avec les sociaux
démocrates
en cas de victoire du spd nouvelle
semaine de turbulences sur les places
boursières tokyo a fermé sa séance à moi
à 3 4% francfort à -1 7% paris clôturer
à -2 sao paulo à -5 et tout à l'heure où
wall street a indiqué d'une baisse de 0
4%
bien évidemment les crises asiatique et
russe donne un climat d'extrême
fragilité mais surtout aujourd'hui ce
sont les banques qui ont subi jardin
claire est absolument c'est leur
dégringolade qui a aujourd'hui entraîné
la chute des bourses de pose de plus en
plus nerveux ces bourses au départ la
quasi faillite aux etats-unis d'un hedge
fund c'est à dire d'un établissement
spécialisé dans les placements au risque
donc hyper spéculatif avec les crises
russe et asiatique la ltcm c'est son nom
se retrouve avec une ardoise de 4
milliards de dollars
or nombre de banques françaises entre
autres lui avait prêté de l'argent d'où
la suspicion et des baisses voisine de
8% aujourd'hui pour la société générale
la bnp ou paribas enfin le sentiment que
la crise a désormais pénétrer le coeur
du système financier occidental mais
plusieurs voix dont celle du
gouvernement français dans celle de
jacques chirac en appelle désormais à
une réforme du système monétaire mondial
absolument la france propose notamment
de renforcer la capacité d'intervention
du fonds monétaire international et de
rétablir des règles du jeu sur les
mouvements de capitaux
moins ambitieux les marchés financiers
réclame plus de transparence pour tous
ceux qui empruntent que ce soit des
états comme la russie ou des sociétés
comme alcatel ou elle que c'est m merci
la traversée à la nage de l'atlantique
un pari réussi pour benoît lecomte qui
aura parcouru 5500 km en mer malgré
l'extrême fatigue le français a commenté
cet exploit qui l'aura conduit à nager
pendant plus de deux mois jacques devaux
gabriel kenya
sur les traces de gérard d'aboville
benoît lecomte lui avait choisi de nager
traverser l'atlantique des etats-unis
vers la france
pas seul bien sûr un bateau
l'accompagner sur lequel il se reposait
après avoir été contraint à une escale
de huit jours aux açores cet après midi
enfin il toucher au but faire le
millième de ce qu'il fallait durant ce
périple de 5500 km benoît devaient nager
en moyenne huit heures par jour
en fait il ne s'est pas réellement
combien de temps il a passées dans l'eau
se refusant à compter les jours je peux
pas mettre le doigt sur une chose qui
est des plus pénibles c'est
l'accumulation l'accumulation petites
choses qui fâchent on remettra ont
parfois dû être maintenant chaque fois
surtout que quand matin ou réveiller et
garder la mer ça bouge encore autant que
le jour avant n'a jamais eu place la
maison de conditions benoît lecomte a
essuyé des tempêtes
il a été victime de nausées l'eau lui
est devenu un supplice mais il avait
choisi de porter la bannière de la lutte
contre le cancer
cela lui a donné la force de continuer
et aujourd'hui il entre dans les annales
nouveaux développements dans la sphère
djamel bouras le judoka qui a été
suspendu pour un an après avoir été
contrôlé positif pourrait être innocenté
une information à mettre au conditionnel
mais certaines instances médicales font
pas aujourd'hui de leurs doutes leurs
ans frédéric bollée dans le bureau du
professeur gallien l'attachement aux
sports est visible c'est peut-être parce
qu'ils apprécient aussi les sportifs que
le président de la commission nationale
de lutte contre le dopage nuance
aujourd'hui le cas bouras voilà
presqu'un an que le judoka a été
contrôlé positif à la nandrolone
or dans ses urines c'est peut-être un
autre produit qu'on aurait en fait
trouvé anabolisants aussi mais non
interdit à l'époque
explications on a retrouvé quelque chose
dans les urines de djamel bouras
imaginer qu'on ait retrouvé des morceaux
de pommes ça veut dire qu'il a à il a
reçu il a ingéré des pommes ce qu'il nie
d'ailleurs seulement des pommes il ya
des pommes vertes qu'il ya des pommes
rouges ya des pommes jaunes et les
morceaux de pommes que j'ai retrouvées
dans les urines ne permettent pas de
dire si c'était la rouge
la jaune ou la verte si la rouge et la
jaune sont interdites
c'est pas la verte eh bien on ne peut
pas affirmer qu'il ya eu dopage
autrement dit la nandrolone peut être
confondu avec autre chose et personne
aujourd'hui est finalement plus sûr de
rien un constat qui intervient alors
qu'une loi de lutte contre le dopage est
à l'étude
les auditions ont d'ailleurs eu lieu à
l'assemblée nationale hier moralité
djamel bouras qui a toujours clamé son
innocence et n'a peut-être pas tort mais
de là à avoir raison c'est autre chose
car il a été suspendu par sa fédération
qui attend maintenant d'en savoir un peu
plus pour l'instant nous restons sur une
déclaration du professeur gallien
personnalité est immeubles mais
j'aimerais que son avis est partagé par
d'autres
la loi contre le dopage devrait être
votée le 18 novembre prochain
mais le cab horace vient illustrer les
difficultés à appréhender
problème si on sait toujours pas un an
après ce caprice champion olympique
comment penser que la lutte sera un jour
efficace et puis deux espagnols ont été
expulsés du tour d'espagne cycliste la
vuelta pour dopage ces coureurs faisait
partie d'un groupe qui a été contrôlée
par l'union cycliste internationale ce
matin yannick noah cheveux ce week-end
sa carrière de capitaine de l'équipe de
france de tennis en israël pour
l'instant la france ce même 2 0
il ne manque plus qu'un point pour
sceller ses adieux avec éclat christelle
bertrand loi et face à pioline et
l'équipe de france est dos au mur
cédric pioline à la charge de gagner le
premier point face à annie raddad plus
de 300 places au classement séparent les
deux hommes
et ça se voit les échanges sont longs
sans coup d'éclat mais pioline ne se
laisse pas endormir le premier set ne
dure que 26 min à part quelques points
plus disputée que les autres rien à
signaler
les deux derniers sets sont du même
registre que le premier tranquillement
sans trop se dépenser que l'hymne
s'impose 6 2 6 3 6 3 la france mène 1 0
noah est rassuré face à harel levy
guillaume broux a eu un début de match
plus compliqué le français a eu du mal à
imposer son jeu et son rythme il
remporte finalement le premier set au
tie break
ensuite les vies a perdu confiance le
français 44e mondial a pris les choses
en main et a facilement remporté les
deux manches suivantes
score final 7 6 6 2 6 4
il ne reste plus qu'un point à marquer
en double pour que nos a fini sa
carrière de capitaine aussi bien tout
n'avait commencé
c'était aussi contre israël la france
avait gagné aujourd'hui à tel aviv les
joueurs de l'équipe de france se sont
déclarés favorables à guy forget en
remplacement de yannick noah le bureau
fédéral doit prendre sa décision le 10
octobre prochain
voile avec demain matin ça l'essonne en
caroline du sud le départ de la course
autour du monde en solitaire avec
escales l'ex-boxeur ng désormais
rebaptisé around alone 16 bateaux au
départ trois navigateurs français dont
le skipper marc thiercelin portrait de
ce marin qui était arrivé deuxième du
vendée globe
christophe duchiron frédéric dazy ici le
paysage est une invitation au tourisme
charleston en caroline du sud où l'on ne
trouve pourtant pas que des touristes
marc thiercelin navigateur français
bientôt 38 ans il est huit heures du
matin il fait le plein d'énergie et de
vie dans la tête une vie à part du calme
avant la tempête
deuxième du dernier vendée globe il
repart au tour du monde en solitaire
avec déjà des envies de solitude j'aime
bien j'aime bien être paisible n'êtes
pas les projecteurs sur plaisir et
surtout avoir le regard des autres dans
tous les sens puis des côtes et qui fera
toute chose une certaine pression de
même que le touriste le marais est un
voyageur ou vieux marché de charleston
marque a enfilé pour quelques minutes
son ami de touristes lui le grand
voyageur qui avec le sénégal en italie
au brésil incitation au voyage
son bateau s'appelle somewhere ce qui en
anglais veut dire quelque part pour la
course
marc thiercelin se situe quelque part
parmi les favoris eu égard à son
expérience et à son bateau monocoque de
18 mètres équipé d'un mât aile rotatif
comprenez qu'il dispose d'une machine de
course qui va l'accompagner au tour du
monde pendant huit mois
on fait quand même 50 de 1000 km c'est
beaucoup
chaque vague va les vagues nous marquent
les endroits qu'on va rencontrer de
nouveau pour nous éduquer nous nous as
trouvé à tout ça s'arrête
ça va être très complet là
naviguez découvrir s'émouvoir
c'est l'univers du voyageur marc
thiercelin en a fait son métier coureur
de fond sommes du grand large
et nous rejoignons maintenant direct de
charleston aux états unis zabel
autissier bonsoir vous êtes la plus
ancienne
oui bonjour pour vous est l'une des
favorites de cette course comment et le
mental à quelques heures de prendre la
mer le mental c'est votre meilleure arme
oui bah ça va super bien parce que prb
mon bateau est bien prêt on a beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé cet été
et puis moi je suis en forme et j'ai
même assez envie d'y aller en fait c'est
une course que j'aime énormément j'aime
bien mon bateau et le fait de sentir
prête à être rapidement ce sera bien
vous partez pour la gagne que m'ont dit
pour gagner cette fois ci voit j'espère
je crois que j'ai un bateau qui peut
gagner qui fait partie moyen très très
beau plateau ici mais enfin il fait
partie des meilleurs bateaux moi je
commence quand même à avoir de
l'expérience des tours du monde deux
heures de course je pense que ça peut
m'aider à gérer correctement le bateau
donc voilà maintenant c'est quand même
un toit du monde dont quelque chose de
très longs beaucoup beaucoup de choses
peuvent arriver et j'espère que ce sera
plutôt des bonnes alors précisément
peut-être dans les moins bonnes choses
un démâtage un naufrage notre bateau
avait fait un tonneau la mer vous êtes
déjà réservé pas mal de surprises
vous avez un peu envie de prendre votre
revanche sais pas si on prend sa
revanche sur la mer je crois que la mer
à l'escalet c'est à nous d'essayer
d'être malin bon c'est vrai qu'il ya
toujours une petite part de chance quand
on navigue bon j'espère avoir mangé mon
pain noir en fait parce que je crois que
ça suffit comme ça et j'espère qu'ils
aient les ventes sont un petit peu plus
favorable la prochaine fois vous serez
en tout cas je fais pas de cauchemars
avec ça quand je pars assez confiante
on s'en souvient pendant le vendée globe
challenge vous étiez parti à la
recherche de gerry roufs en reprenant la
mer est ce que son image est présente
elle vous accompagne où elle va peut
être réfrénés vos ardeurs
c'est sûr que c'est quelqu'un à qui je
pense est acquis je penserai quand je
repartirai demain parce que je crois que
c'est sûrement la chose la plus terrible
de perdre quelqu'un de perdre quelqu'un
en mer bon je crois que
ça fait un petit peu partie de notre
métier de savoir vivre avec ça mais on y
pense et en même temps on fait tout ce
qu'il faut pour que ça n'arrive pas ça
reste dans un coin il faut pas
s'angoisser avec sa fouille pensé voilà
et puis un elysée avoir une expérience
et et s'arranger pour regarder le danger
le plus loin possible
on va tenter peut-être une dernière
question de partager avec vous une de
ces longues journées que vous aurez
durant ce voyage qu'ils sont les heurts
dans cette seule journée qui sont les
plus difficiles les plus pénibles pour
vous vous redoutez parfois aubin en
général c'est plutôt les heures de nuit
bon nous on vit là jour et le jour et la
nuit on dort partout petites tranches et
en général les heures on est plus
fatigué donc pousser facilement
dangereux c'est les heures de phan huy
lê trois heures 6 heures du matin quand
la fatigue s'accumule on guette le lever
du soleil
c'est un peu une délivrance est à la
fois c'est très beau et très magique et
en même temps souvent on est crevé un
nom un peu marre et on a vraiment envie
que le jour se lève pour que la vie soit
un petit peu plus facile
écoutez on vous souhaite une excellente
course isabelle autissier andré comte à
votre à votre retour soyez prudentes au
revoir jean paul belmondo fait sa
rentrée théâtrale dans un rôle à sa
mesure celui de frédérick lemaître un
comédien du 19e siècle qui fit les beaux
soirs du boulevard du crime sans et
d'égout bernard qu csokas calcul un rôle
sur mesure pour belmondo qui aiment le
panache celui de l'acteur le plus
pittoresque du 19e siècle frédéric
lemaître
sur la pointe des pieds aura dans l'urne
caché derrière votre grande qu'un s'est
agrandie automne qu'est-ce qu'il ferait
sans suite achoui faites moi confiance
c'est bien là la difficulté
bravo c'est exactement ça le mec a été
vraiment le roi du boulevard on
l'appelait le lion du bouloir tout le
monde se prostituer possibilité voire
les lois la chance doivent aider
justement des brasseurs des jules berry
les six mondes et jouvet et je trouve
c'est une école formidable et je pense
que tout ce monde là
et bien c'est un peu frédéric cornette
qui était le père spirituel de tous ses
journaux
oui précieuse connais-tu le rôle d'abel
d'anthony naturellement cette blague
mais ça tombe bien du dew ce soir
frédéric lemaître tombe amoureux d'une
femme plus jeune que lui le vrai thème
de la pièce c'est choisir entre le
théâtre et la vie choisir entre l'amour
jouer et là mon vécu
tout le regarde comme si c'était la
dernière fois que je te regarder ces de
caresses comme si c'était la dernière
fois que j'ai tout cas récent a tant
fait pareil
le baiser comme si
le regard comme si le caresse comme si
mais tu pleures
avant ces comédiens qui s'applique de
l'émotion de la verve onze changements
de décors seize comédiens un spectacle
qui se veut populaire au sens noble du
terme et vont celui-là ainsi se termine
ce journal vous rappelle les principes
éthiques
un homme de 36 ans un marginal reconnaît
le meurtre d'adrien ce jeune adolescent
dont on avait découvert le corps au
début du mois d'août dernier dans un
blockhaus près de thionville ses aveux
ne signifie pas la culpabilité la
conférence de presse de salman rushdie
look ou de la liberté retrouvée pour
l'auteur des versets sataniques après la
décision de l'iran de se désolidariser
de la plume sur sa tête dans un instant
la météo nathalie rihouet puis le point
route valérie maurice de master dont il
caffè quelqu'un c'est là que reçoit
edith cresson
je vous retrouve demain dès 13h merci
notre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2